vous pourrez lire alors mais alors là
vraiment car bien joué moins lourd qu'un
de plats des yeux doux maintenant on
fait un peu le public a bâti des
privations dit horaire moi je veux
manger à tout ça vous mangez les oignons
sans confitures de fruits vous fera en
vrai c'est qu'ils n'ont pas trop de
temps finalement entre midi et deux pour
manger un petit encas comme
inconsistantes
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui on va jouer à faire du
clap géante bien 257 peu frais et on y
mélange la moitié de son poids de l'âge
[Musique]
vous vous souvenez de la bouffe je veux
dire avant que tout s'effondre vous
souvenez de la bouffe
partout des tonnes de bouffe tellement
de bouffe que c'était devenu toute une
culture
[Musique]
bon
on prétend que porte en serait le plus
solide appétit cochon il
qu'est-ce qu'on était bien avant que le
monde se casse la gueule on manquait de
rien la corne d'abondance
on en aurait presque oublié le temps où
la nourriture c'était avant tout un
besoin quelque chose qui pouvait se
faire rare un temps pas si lointain
pourtant comme s'en souvenait encore
dans leur chair même nos anciens ayant
connu les affres d'une bonne grosse
guerre mais voilà il avait suffi d'une
ou deux générations de rien du tout pour
oublier tout l'histoire d'une humanité
qui ne prenait pas un ventre plein pour
acquis enfin dans l'abondance pas pour
tout le monde
pendant la première grève politique de
l'histoire soviétique
évidemment les pénuries se sont
aggravées mais après tout on pouvait
bien s'offusquer des privations dans
d'affreuses dictature pas de quoi en
faire un régime ici et quelques images
de famine à l'autre bout du monde ça
tire une petite larme de temps en temps
pas de quoi couper l'appétit quand même
d'ailleurs comme le disaient nos vieux
il y a des petits enfants qui meurent de
faim en afrique alors fini ton assiette
de la bouffe nous on en avait tellement
on pouvait se permettre un petit geste
de temps en temps mais à part ça
quand l'appétit va tout va et l'appétit
il allait tellement bien que manger
c'était pas juste manger ah non manger
c'était un plaisir c'était un arbre les
petits plats confectionnés chez soi
c'est bien mais avouez que les temples
de la gastronomie reste tout de même les
restaurants la culture de la table a
franchi des impératifs de rareté elle
pouvait se faire créative et
pointilleuse se permettre des règles de
bon goût des codes de bonne tenue et des
méthodes complexes bref trêve de
subsistance place à la gastronomie
l'homme civilisé pouvait se faire
difficile je déplore le grignotage la
barre chocolatée de merde à 10 heures du
matin le cornec pommes frites et causse
à midi ou le sandwich de mauvais pain
avec un jambon polyphosphates et c'est
ça qu'il faut éviter à tout prix à la
fin même la culture de la cuisine wc
grands artistes de véritables rock stars
on les appelait même des chefs c'est
vous dire à l'avc au lieu comme autant
de louvres de la boustifaille elle avait
ses écoles ses modes et ses courants
surtout en france parce que entre nous
la cuisine anglaise
dans l'infinité des traditions
culinaires de par le monde là aussi on
voulait être les coques même que des
fois un peu chauvin en se méfier un peu
des autres
les jolies cuse alimentaire des
habitants du pays du soleil levant nous
paraissent d'extraordinairement curieuse
et leurs repas sauf rares exceptions
nous retourne l'estomac
les plats sont froids feddal dès qu'ils
sentent mauvais de poissons séchés
est-il aussi parce que le pays des
droits de l'homme ne comptait pas que
sur eux pour rayonner
d'ailleurs si on y regarde bien les
droits de l'homme et la bête ans à
quelques points communs la révolution
française ça a été l'occasion de signer
quelques déclarations universelles
certes en mettant au passage fin aux
privilèges des nobles et cela dépossédé
en fuite ou tout bonnement plus ils ont
laissé sur le carreau un paquet de gens
de maison dont des gens cuisinent qu'ils
allaient pouvoir mêmes devoirs en fait
s'ils voulaient eux mêmes
ironie du sort continuer à se nourrir
faire profiter de leurs talents à des
clients aux cent - bleus alors voilà que
la cuisine après le peuple descendait
elle aussi dans la rue
plus question qu'elle soit réservée à
une caste ou cantonné aux chez soi comme
toutes les cultures celle de la bouffe
avait son versant populaire des plates
pauvre arranger des festivités grand
public ou communautaire des spécialités
du terroir taillé sur mesure pour les
réalités locales
regardez avec dédain par la grande
cuisine bourgeoise mais n'empêchant pas
une certaine fierté
après tout une gastronomie du peuple par
le peuple et pour le peuple quoi de plus
démocratique
tant qu'a hérité de la révolution
française d'autant qu'au tradition du
coin et aux recettes de grand mère cette
culture populaire de la bonne chère se
démocratiser via les livres mais aussi
la téloche
si ce livre avait concouru pour le prix
goncourt il est sûr qu'il aurait obtenu
cette année faisant de la cuisine ce
soir elle nous n'avons pas besoin de tes
fameuse race
rendez vous compte on pouvait même
regarder des gens cuisinent comme ça à
l'antenne devant des millions de
téléspectateurs qui ne pourraient même
pas en croquer en bout et on adoré ça
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour mais l'été bouche
franchement os qu'ailleurs à la télé
française tellement uniforme socialement
on pouvait entendre en parler si populo
et un accent qui sent si bon la province
puis il faut dire que la cuisine des
mousquetaires c'était plus porthos et
aramis
on n'était pas là pour la diététique
clairement bref maïté c'était une
cuisine à laquelle le peuple pouvait
s'identifier
enfin quoique parce qu'en vrai qu'ils
pouvaient faire ses recettes
finalement maïté d'accord ça sentait bon
terroir mais ça reste de fait plus de la
cuisine de gouvernante que de la cuisine
pour tous ah bah oui pour faire la
popote
il faut de la place le bon matériel les
nouveaux ingrédients
sérieusement vous vous rendez compte que
ça coûtait des produits comme ça dans de
telles quantités et il faut le savoir
faire aussi et surtout du temps je
promets de penser le 31 mai à hong kong
et d'oublier ma dextérité à ouvrir les
boîtes de conserves m'avait appris mais
la seconde affaire le cassoulet comme le
faisait votre maman et comme le faisait
votre grand mère
vous avez sûrement appris autre chose à
prendre mon temps et je n'ai pas
l'intention de me dépêcher pour savourer
votre cas sous les voies l'appétit
madame
et ce à quoi de mieux que la fin du
monde pour nous le rappeler nous
rappeler que l'abondance ça vous tombe
pas tout cuit dans le bec et qu'on
mangeait pas tous au même resto ceux qui
se retrouvaient dans notre assiette ça
n'avait rien de magique
c'était le fruit du travail de tout un
monde un monde qui plantait élevé
chasser et récolté mais aussi
transformer en pacte est acheminée et
distribuée à ceux qui pourrait payer et
qui balance elle reste au lieu de
partager le fruit de ce labeur comme une
bonne excuse pour être ensemble
on s'était transformé en domestique les
uns des autres les uns plus que les
autres d'ailleurs dans cette obsession
d'avoir pour soi aussi petit fut-elle sa
part du gâteau on avait bien voulu
oublier que l'abondance avait un prix le
prêt de la cruauté du massacre aveugle
de l'exploitation sans fin pour
satisfaire quelques appétits insatiables
on avait oublié surtout qu'à un moment
il ne resterait que des images
alléchantes d'une opulence passagère et
qu'à la toute fin
il fallait payer la note au bout d'un
merci qui oui déguster ce que je vous
rejoins
[Musique]
donc tu que je vous ai côtoyé ma place
chose assez aussi beaucoup y avoir ce
courage et je suis quand je suis sur de
larges et salat-baroux mais les vraies
marges je suis avez vous de tout coeur
est avec vous régalez vous avec moi en
même temps
[Musique]